[Music]
and pick for me news mmm
pick up boogers baby babies submitted by
love from New York
hey no you're but a pizza a what's up
New York
oh my god this airline is offering
ridiculously cheap flights to surprise
to sleep I mean how do you while we talk
about two dollars here in Syria
destinations yeah surprise doesn't mean
good what some of these flights
Oh - mmm I like these questions no I'm
good welcome to Iraqi since October you
can tell haha that's why we never ask
these questions so Lufthansa is offering
round-trip flights starting at 9 min and
then never then I know my son's a little
south of Germany right it is [ __ ]
cheap guten tag that's how you say hello
you guys are gonna like this what it's
only if you're departing from Munich or
Frankfurt that's still good though for
people in Munich you okay okay even if
you're China so let's say you're trying
to travel which I'm doing Europe tour
you could just fly to Munich right and
you kick it there for a couple days and
then if you want to go to another
country then not only 100 bucks not true
okay good you saw the prices yeah he
says out of Munich yeah you have to
depart from me I was minute if you're
trying to set up a little tour now I
never been there I'm not that cultured
yeah so what they're offering is
surprise romantic destination which is
Athens Bologna Budapest
Florence below it was a great dope house
because Rome Venice Vienna and Dirk tell
two kinds of cured meat Vienna Bologna
yeah Danya pronto romantic destination
what where's Bologna in the fridge
already fine but
do you think that's where it comes from
really the loneliest delicious dude and
inducing vinius Vienna sausage comes
from Vienna I did it from Austria Vienna
in Austria today yeah from David what do
you think Vienna sausage comes from
there I know the little ones you don't
like them yeah you only like you don't
know how to get a ghetto there was there
like earthquake preparation prep kit
food yes a job I couldn't wait till I
got my earthquake kit back because that
sort of better than my mom's going to
know with the crackers right oh I love
that favorite the to know what the
cracker I couldn't like I couldn't so we
have to you know in the beginning of
elementary school you have to make the
earthquake kids yeah you give it to the
teacher when I got it back with the
[ __ ] peanut butter cracker sandwich
thing and a novena saw hell yeah lunch
today
this little just like oh my God we're
garbage today anyways back to the
presentation so then I also have these
bromance trip what about Fishman keep
girl fresh but destinations it's after
dam Berlin Budapest Dublin Hamburg crap
all the hooker places is that what a
crazy places I get party destinations
yeah but as soon as I heard Amsterdam
Berlin I was like oh that's why I think
that's where prostitution is legal
internet in and they also have these
nature destination neutrals bear with me
I'm going to try pronounce this belt so
the first one is Belgrade Copenhagen
Faro banks Geneva thanks you ha ha ha ha
thank you Tom and Toulouse to do this so
that's all if I get up yes yes I like
the nature ones mm-hmm I'm down with
that
contrary to everyone's beliefs thinking
I'm going after dam with Michael you
know you would that's a good deal though
yeah if you get your way to Europe you
can have all kinds of flights like I
think so pretty much ten flights for a
grant
yeah so a lot of places I don't know if
it really is a deal though because I
know like we can you I know you flying
right but you can catch everything
on a train hmm or like drive through it
so let me the fact or not that is faster
have you guys ever taken the metro here
yes yeah it smells like tea tea don't
like it I don't enjoy that I took here
from East LA to Chinatown and for some
reason it was free that day so I just
walked on it I didn't pay anything how
long did that take
it took [ __ ] forever god damn it
should be like five minutes over like 20
minutes I took them I don't know if it's
the Metro but whatever's at the Union
Station all the way to Santa Barbara not
was pleasant that's why the Train yeah
that's the islands right in the dam
check that isn't really different yeah
yeah definitely different that's legit
trains like it takes from downtown to go
to like let's say like Culver City will
take like 45 minutes but I guess like if
you think about it in a sense that
during traffic time it's better it's a
wee fee I'm not sure you know what they
do on Amtrak they have their own rooms
like you could get like a bed and a bunk
bed and like food service to get to like
just New Mexico or something it takes
like oh it's pretty cool whatever but
what I really want to do actually is
like AM Trek has like that bed service
right where you have like the upgrade is
like their first class thing where you
have a whole section off area generally
had right but then there's one that goes
from here to like Seattle and Portland
and hurling it's like the scene is
amazing oh and on the upper deck there's
like restaurants on top oh [ __ ] so you
could just do that and then it takes
like I think like a day or two mm-hmm
but you're just kind of like enjoying
the experience and just hanging out I
just take the Amtrak every week in high
school because I went to this military
school in San Diego and then most most
of the military kids are parents -
ladies and cook them up so every Friday
out get on the Amtrak and I met all
these homeless people became friends
with them and then one of them is named
impossible and I met a matter rate and
then he told me he told me he's getting
married that day and I was rolling on
ecstasy
so I'm so happy for him and then all
that where's the ring and then he showed
me the ring pop that he bought and he
split it on the girls finger she was
waiting down all go into and then I
could have sworn I was like his best man
Wow I never seen him ever again when he
was in hospital you're too nice cuz that
was horrible
that's like a crackhead marriage all the
goodness it's a crackhead saddlebags
that was weird
notice I met him at the train station
and then he was like dancing and stuff
and I'll tell him to raving and popping
at the time so I was like all [ __ ]
and I met him and it was like autumn
possible and the water declare
Impossibles check this out he climbs on
top of the coast vending machine he does
a backflip am i impossible so she could
do all kinds of crazy [ __ ] little bit of
back footage that both legs face
impossible ha ha ha and I met him in San
Diego this [ __ ] homeless flood I met
him in downtown on a race Wow the
International homeless man we're not in
a splinter station in a California he's
just a travel yeah just have a seat the
homeless [ __ ] beautiful exactly what he
is
can you imagine if a homeless person had
a vlog camera like what their day would
be like Yeah right there right good job
I have a house
it's boring now no I don't if I lived
like a real homeless man it would be
dude if you gave a homeless person like
a flan its Skid Row
Oh see what goes down I probably would
have to like like blur out a lot of like
as well as some crazy [ __ ] like
especially inside the tents almost
wondering what's going on inside this
case I don't think that we haven't be
like I don't think that people would
even let them flogged because then as
soon as they see a camera they're like
no I don't know tell me no oh my god
what is it like those Palladian one of
their long security yeah they just hate
paparazzi coming down because they get
so much of that what if you one of their
own
that's different like a bum King right
the baddest bumpkins oh yeah so they
have to live it in there leave it to the
pump
there's bunky what are bunking bum kings
are the people who no joke like they're
known as like the guy of that certain
area they run a lot every bum circle has
a king this is still fast me yeah like
no Joe I thought all the jokes I said I
got mine I'm Joe Mallya my friend my
friend has that front
cop and he was telling him where after
he told me that uh those are bunking and
the OSI that just passed away him a new
one
just came here just got what I got
thought it was a joke but he's like it's
for real like that's what the cop is
saying like there's a bum king and hosi
there's one in LA I gave certain areas
and the one one of the the one in OC
just got murdered so there's like a new
pumpkin OC right now took his power know
what what are they like the duties about
I don't I don't know I want to go out
and make a documentary about the bug
yeah I'll be [ __ ] sick because I need
to know no watch that the king of bums I
feel like it's like territorial you know
I mean or something like you could stand
this block you could stay here this is
your corner they have the rules for sure
they have like Horry rules and all that
because I live in downtown LA and just
certain areas are just claimed by
certain bums like there's tents and
people just know they're like spacing
and all that stuff and how do they do
that there's like one group here another
group there Wow you know one time I was
at the flower market it saw something
really disturbing I saw a guy pulling
into a bucket I mean she doesn't
inaudible that's not even that bad I've
never seen someone proving in public
that happens all the time
they'll squat in front of you in the
middle of the street and just go and you
see the Dookie stream going out of the
butthole one time there's this homeless
lady giving Isaac a very motivating and
heartwarming speech that's the whole
time her upper butt crack was showing
like like four inches of it uh-huh and I
pass about to fall off it's just
teaching I reject that you have to
listen to your mom and do all these
awesome things back to me pay attention
you know on Vermont where the McDonald
did that no one McDonald's in Vermont
there was a dude sitting what you call
that [ __ ] by squatting Indians to Odin
he said we call this the squat god yeah
what eating a [ __ ] can of beans okay
with the straw [ __ ] do the the blue beds
with the holes in it oh you stay in a
[ __ ] eating a can of beef idiot with a
strider picture but i feel bad no
first off like dude look at this [ __ ]
there look at the picture I was like
this is actually really sad so I deleted
it'll be great for you yeah I just was I
never seen that before should have
submitted to the humans in New York ha
ha ha can you that awesome captions dad
they need to do humans of LA yeah I've
been to New York and they do not the
city is totally different we have a
specific look out here yeah you're
either really [ __ ] rich or really
[ __ ] poor or your college students or
hipsters it's just like or are youtubers
youtubers yes or a or immigrant won't
you start it may be humans of la jolla
hola awesome
zombies are Ola no no how we went from
surprised as a nation to people with his
sorry about like an international
travelers from San Diego to out downtown
LA what are all my positive people I
want to hear your thoughts put it in the
comments below because if you're
negative shut the hell up and go drink
some raid please but if you're very
positive leave it in the comments below
for the last video over here